This week,
Matt and I took the kids to one of our favorite local restaurants
for dinner. Bone by me is a local Charleston institution
and just opened their newest location in the Oakland Shopping Center
in Mount Pleasant. And we hadn't gone to check them out yet
and we knew they had some incredible specials.
I love that they have a kids menu
that lets kids be in control of what they eat on their plate.
Selections of meats, sides,
and additions. We decided to get a couple appetizers for the table
before jumping into the main dishes.
The Brussels sprouts and cauliflower were absolutely delicious,
and the shishito peppers with the garlic dipping sauce was divine.
The kids both ended up getting ground pork tacos
and absolutely loved them.
My favorite, though,
were these stir fried udon noodles,
which are only at this Northmount Pleasant location,
along with the duck FA.
These were definitely dishes that were worth the drive over for.
And of course, we had to share the duck fried rice
because the entire family is obsessed with it.
I love being able to get really high quality food in a casual setting.
It makes weekday dinners with the kids so much easier.
Bone by me is a regular takeout spot for us,
but now I know
I'm gonna have to go to Northmount Pleasant
to get those stir fried noodles again. Go check them out soon!